dea
今から日本語な列車を行います
日本には梅雨というものがある雨の季節というふうに翻訳する人が多いですが
正確に言うとうつの季節かただし大雨が降るのはもちろんのこと
恋人ば霧氷所でアナと降り黒い就職活動が始まるのも
この時期泊月に入ると日本に住んでいるすべての人は打ち込むということで今日は2を
無事に過ごし切るためのアドバイスを紹介したいと思う
是非活用して下さい池今寝るときは柴犬の子犬の動画を見ること
何があっても火垂るの墓を見ないこと政治家の twitter
を一切見ないこと5 htp を蓄えることビタミン d を蓄えること
ハーゲンダッツのクリスピーさあのキャラメルクラシックを蓄えること気晴らしに
スマホの機種変更をしないこと就活中なランドリーシート100万円以上書くと期待
することにも関わらず仕事が見つからないと期待することという状況なのに市民税で
さらに便
もうになると期待することは元恋人からの古いメールを読まないこと
要注意懸命に絵文字が入ったものは特に危険体重計を隠すこと地鶏のフィルターを倍に
することをひたすら右スワイプをすることを傘を盗まれる覚悟をすること傘がないから
びっしょり濡れると覚悟をすることびっしょり濡れてしまったからか
手を引いてしまうと覚悟することをお酒を飲まないことどうしても飲みたいなら
梅雨明けまで毎晩豪華を飲むこと切ない音楽を聞かないことどうしても聞きたいなら
ひたすらぬ者ペースを聞くこと雨が降っているときに自分のお母さんに電話しないこと
何か失敗した時に3日間以内に自分のお父さんと話さないこと
何気なく自分の髪
にを自分で切ってみないこと雨のせいで交通事故にを国保すること事故のせいで学校や
会社に遅刻する国語をすること遅刻のせいで怒られ最も凹んでる時に新しいカーサ盗ま
れる確保すること男性なら自分よりかっこいい友達のフェイスブックを見ないこと女性
なら自分より可愛い友達のインスタを見ないこと
とそしてユーチューバーだったら絶対にデミオ見ないこと
ん
ni